un seul de ses 14 aventuriers succèdera
à lionel qui a remporté les 450 euros
une somme folle
ces deux-là terme de folie on va grimper
un petit step je crois c'est un festival
de vannes c'est complètement fou les
premiers tête vous dire c'est le seul
moyen de faire du poids rapide non c'est
pas possible entre les les cas sociaux
les débiles tu es vraiment chez les
dingues tout est possible ça qui est
génial et je vais dire le meilleur comme
le pire mais moi j'adore le pire
évidemment du bellay trahi
on peut à mon avis clairement profité et
regardez le flambeau sans avoir vu la
femme c'est sûr mais si vraiment vous
avez aimé la flamme vous allez adorer le
flambeau qu'est ce qu'il est devenu
l'animateur de la flamme pour les manger
le vrai concept qui lui plaisait déjà
c'était d'imaginer qu'on s'a thierry
they une émission de télé réalité
différente à chaque fois vous êtes sûr
que celle là parce qu'il ya pas de vide
armoires ne sais même pas où il revient
me revient sur une autre émission de
télé réalité car malgré un bateau
construit ou même de construire avec
quoi anne nos mains peut-être ils
pensent que c'est toujours une émission
de dating donc il croit toujours qu'il
va trouver l'amour laventure bah moi une
aventure d'un soir ça me va très bien et
il comprend pas il sait quoi cette
émission de merde c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on m'a dit pour l'instant c'est
n'importe quoi l'émission ouais je crois
que le gros gain c'est de se dire une
bonne série c'est qu'on a envie de
retrouver les personnages on avait le
sentiment qu'il ya des personnages pour
avoir envie de retrouver et là on va
faire un petit exercice d'accord c'est
pas ça l'exercice est bien tous ces
nouveaux personnages vont émerger qu'il
n'y avait absolument pas tomassi mes
caméras le rappel par an
gérard darmon la job dating jamais la
corse le cas si jonathan je vais envie
de ça par contre ça a bien dormi et bien
oui ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
fait une bonne grosse
connerie au point que sireau sauvegarde
sa phase kim s'est vite sellal aventure
en fait
[Applaudissements]
un cousin parce qu'il me ferait en fait
moi c'est justement ces équipes qui ne
se connaissent pas qu'ils doivent
proposer les uns avec les autres il ya
forcément des antagonismes votre compte
remis ce soir 3 ils savent très bien
qu'ils passent à la télé ils savent très
bien les codes ouais c'est pas du prof
si les parcs ont fait un truc est donc
en vrai il en joue pour certains c'est
plus semblant m'énerver ce matin là oui
c'est exactement ça qui fait la guerre
les gens sur les réseaux c'est plus
centré sur moi s'est centrée sur tous
les personnages mais je pense que c'est
ça aussi qui va rapporter beaucoup de
diversité puis de renouveau aussi par
rapport à la saison un
autre chasseur patrice ça me plaît
l'idée que ce soit très border no
censure de toute façon canal pour le
coup ils sont vraiment nos potes là de
suite mais non et encore de la place
aujourd'hui pour des séries loufoque
dingue et c'est ça qui compte parce que
c'est ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir dans le
panorama français
[Musique]
quel sera le prochain aventuriers
éliminés vous le saurez en regardant le
prochain épisode du flambeau